And as the war in Ukraine drags
on, opponents of President
Vladimir Putin face a risky decision.
Do they challenge the Kremlin
and speak out against the war?
Well, Putin's
critics face danger,
even death, for speaking out.
Details from CNN's senior
international correspondent
Matthew Chance.
Yeah, yeah,
I guess I
It takes a certain type of bravery
to stand up to the Kremlin
across the country.
This using arrests and beatings
to crush dissent
against the Ukrainian forces and
some anti-war
protesters even drafted into the army
in a cruel punishment for pacifism.
So it now 60 P of any
political opposition.
Always a risky business
in Putin's Russia.
He's now essentially outlaws who
with prominent opposition leaders
like Ilya Yashin,
recently sentenced to eight
and a half years in jail for criticizing
the conflict
This will
all end soon, he shouts in defiance.
But there's
little real reason for optimism.
This was Vladimir Kara-Murza,
another leading Russian opposition
figure in Moscow, back in 2015
after surviving a suspected poisoning
at the hands of Kremlin agents.
He was allegedly poisoned again
in 2017 and survived that too
only to be imprisoned last April
on charges
ranging from disobeying the police
to treason.
The price of silence
Kara-Murza wrote from jail
was simply unacceptable.
That the price
of speaking out against Putin's
Russia is extraordinarily high too.
Case in point
the former president of Georgia country
lost a brief war with Russia in 2008.
My small nation will never give up
freedom will never give a square mile.
Two years ago,
Mikhail Saakashvili
was imprisoned in Georgia
and what his supporters say
were trumped up charges.
Now this one time Putin foe is at
death's door, allegedly poisoned too,
and accusing Moscow
of orchestrating his plight.
The Kremlin rejects the allegation,
but his family are adamant
to put somebody in this state
after just a year of imprisonment.
That's that was unexpected.
But for
years, Kremlin critics
have been ruthlessly silenced.
Like Anna Politkovskaya,
Russia's most prominent
investigative journalist,
until she was gunned down
in her Moscow apartment building in 2006
Or Alexander Litvinenko,
a former Russian
FSB agent,
poisoned in London in the same year
with a radioactive isotope in 2018.
A former Russian spy, Sergei Skripal,
and his daughter
were poisoned in Britain
using a potent nerve agent.
They survived
propaganda
for years before.
Russia's leading opposition figure,
Boris Nemtsov,
was shot dead
within sight of the Kremlin.
Of course,
the Kremlin denies
any connection to any crime,
but exiled, jailed, poisoned or killed.
Is how so many of Putin's critics
seem to act.
Matthew Chance, CNN, London.